c'est la nouvelle la plus étonnante de
la semaine en autriche on a retrouvé un
homme de plusieurs centaines d'années
inutile de vous préciser qu'il était
mort il s'agit en fait d'un corps
restitués par un glacier qui a donc été
conservés cela dit une polémique s'est
déjà engagée sur son âge marie-françoise
griot glacial
conserver pendant des années par le
froid voici le corps d'un homme mort il
y as sans doute plus d'un siècle
partiellement nul homme semble être
décédé dans des circonstances
dramatiques puisqu'ils portent des
traces de blessures à la tête et dans le
dos à quelques indices pourraient mettre
les chercheurs sur la piste de son
origine il portait un pantalon de cuir
dont le bas était remplie de foin pour
le protéger du froid ces pièces étaient
enveloppées de lanières de cuir et il
tenait à la main une hache artisanale
les spécialistes de la montagne sont
partagés certains pensent qu'il serait
mort il ya près de 500 ans d'autres
jugent invraisemblable qu'il ait pu
rester aussi longtemps prisonnier des
glaces
le corps a été transporté à l'institut
médico-légal d'innsbruck le top 6 mais
permettra d'en savoir plus sur cet
alpiniste d'un autre siècle
[Musique]